Speaker 1: All right. Final Trump event
from the weekend that I want to go over.
Donald Trump gave a statement of some kind. The
lighting used for a while. Now, the lighting has
been terrible on these Trump videos. The new
thing now is that the camera is out of focus
and also the audio is out of sync with the
video. So what you hear doesn't seem to line
up with Trump's mouth. Very strange speech,
but sadly, one of Trump's main big priorities
if he were to become your president again,
is that he will put God back in schools,
which is a really horrible thing to hear.
Speaker 2: So to traditional religious teachings,
under my leadership, we will bring back
God to our schools and our public squares,
and that will happen very quickly. On day one,
we will begin to find these radical zealots and
Marxists who have infiltrated the federal
Department of Education, and we will have
them escorted from the building. Right.
Speaker 1: So day one, they will find
Marxists of whom there are essentially
none in positions of power anywhere,
and they will fire them, I guess, and escort them
out, pandering to the so-called evangelicals,
pandering to the so-called moral majority. And
all of this is it's really unclear that this is
a good idea. This next clip I'm going to play for
you, is Trump going hard anti-abortion? And again,
when you look at public opinion, it is not
obvious that the anti-abortion direction
is the right way to go.
Speaker 2: Who will stand proudly
in defense of innocent life, just as I did for
four very powerful, strong years, because every
child born and unborn is a sacred gift from God.
Speaker 1: So standard hardline, anti-abortion
language, except the country keeps moving left
on that issue. And the anti-abortion push in the
wake of Roe v Wade's repeal was not a good
thing for Republicans. Last clip here This
one seems to be in sync, which is good, better,
better quality at this point in time. But again,
Trump spreading anti-abortion lies.
Speaker 2: I will continue to stand
strong against the extreme late term. Abortion is
in the Democrat Party who believe in abortion on
demand in the ninth month of pregnancy and even
executing babies after birth. They actually talk
beyond birth after birth, executing the baby.
Speaker 1: Untrue. Of course, this has been
widely debunked. There's simply no evidence
of it. Part of this was claimed to be out of
New York. Couldn't find any evidence
of it. Part of it was, I believe,
Virginia. They repeat it and repeat it. If
you want to understand how that claim enters,
does lacks the standard lexicon of abortion.
Check out my clip from Thursday, The Anatomy
of Right Wing Propaganda, and it'll tell you how
rumor becomes stated as if it were fact at the
very top of the Republican Party. Insane weekend
for Trump. It's going to be a crazy week for Joe
Biden is well expected to announce his reelection.
We will have it all after this break. We will
check in on where is Ron DeSantis. Turns out he's
not in Florida again and much more. Stay with us.